lay prone upon the ground is sony pours
a bucket of digital goodies on your
waiting body ready let's do this sony is
now giving away two games for each of
their platforms every month oh and one
more change you now get every game on
the same day so clear your schedule on
Tuesday because you're going to be
swimming in games so let's get this
thing started trying to leave the pack
this month for one very important reason
it's gorgeous seriously just look at all
that verdict beauty what you want to
know how it plays who cares just auto
the stunning artistic design next up is
pixel junk shooter ultimix i can already
hear the scoffs of commenters lamenting
that full of ps4 games are from indie
developers well shut your wine holes
pixel junk is incredibly fun and that's
way more important than worrying about
its budget all right I'm moving on to
the PlayStation 3 it's the perfect time
of year for NBA 2k14 to be given away
isn't it the Pacers look poised to once
again break my heart with Dwyane Wade
flopping his way to a fourth ring having
a digital outlet for my basketball
frustrations is the perfect elixir ps3
peeps also get Sly Cooper thieves in
time it's a nice looking entry in a
genre that's all but dead oh how i miss
you 3d platformers so download this baby
and pray with me that cartoony
adventures mount a comeback this
generation finally let's scope out that
Vita lineup terraria maybe a couple
years old now but it's incredibly
special it's like that minecraft game
everyone's been buzzing about but you
know it's actually fun there's a free
box quote for you and last but certainly
not least is mutant mudds deluxe this is
the only game on this list I haven't
actually played but I'm giving it a
thumbs up anyway of course platformers
are my bag you can't go wrong when it's
free drat I almost want this whole video
without saying the word free oh well
feel free to bicker in the comments
about whether or not these games
actually
cost you anything or not I'll be too
busy playing them to care